gigi gorgeous uh gonna do a proper intro
for gigi gorgeous for once emily if you
want to pull up with google so that if i
miss something i'll be i'm right here
i'll let you know okay um but i just i
don't want to be saying stunning and
you're like actually breathtakingly
beautiful i mean i'm shut up i'm gonna
get some of the adjectives wrong okay so
gigi gorgeous i'm gonna not do justice
to this because during gigi gorgeous the
floor ascent
i was hustling and
working twice as hard to get half as far
and just having
guys grab my ass and stuff so i
discovered gigi gorgeous after
she had built
this empire of
um
greatness
uh read gigi gorgeous book just i mean i
think i just read it like a couple
months ago did you read it yeah yeah
yeah and so well it was before i came on
your podcast right so i am the bitch
that does my homework and sometimes i
will not have a guest on until i'm ready
to know everything about them because i
came up in this business going on talk
shows with men
and i'd be like oh my second special and
they'd be like you do stand up right and
you don't want to miss something like
after the fact you're like oh fuck i had
them like for an hour and i didn't ask
them about this because i'm like
compelled to talk about it i was asking
them things that could be googled so my
thing is on this podcast i will not ask
one question that could be googled you i
love that oh i'm here for this i had a
huge youtube channel you you can find
all that this is why sometimes i don't
do intros because i'm like you'll google
it but emily is right you guys do want
context right um because huh
speaking of context gigi gorgeous
he said she said oh and then then nova's
here nova's been on the show before nova
is might explain why she's here
right
then say it no
i'm uncle i'm unclear
no we're all actually i actually even
asked nova what are you guys doing
makeup for and she goes because i was
asked to be here
well like she doesn't even know if gigi
gorgeous comes on your podcast you
better try to get your face beat that's
what i thought i assumed that so gigi
has fucked up the bell curve so now we
all have to scramble
cause i'm a bull dyke if i have like i
you fucked it up oh my god as if i was
gonna come not in hair and makeup the
trans women just came and like threw out
the old fucking
scorecard score system uh-huh everything
you thought you once knew now you don't
i thought i liked myself
i thought i was looked pretty good and
then i fucking meet you yeah i don't
like you i love you and i'm like i okay
you fucked up the bell curve it's fine i
have other skills and i have their
talents and i'm now dating someone so i
don't need to be male gays pretty
because i don't need to attract more
anything else anything it's too much
bandwidth so
gigi um
can i say trans icon or can i just say
icon am i if i say trans icon that's
like someone saying she's a female
comedian right you know what i actually
i want to know what you have to say
about it i just don't want you um
putting your jewelry on for the sound
issue of that oh my god that's the only
first thing can't touch the walls
because of the spackle uh-huh um which i
also learned no that that was plaster
the spackle is what she's applying to me
right now so this is nova kaplan the
great nova kaplan
i'm not saying christina
is chrissy's real name
no i'm not saying it's christine i'm
sorry that chrissy christy teagan is
naturally gorgeous 100
but what you see on instagram is a
confluence of her genetics and nova
gaplin a beat okay so just fyi
okay going back to what you asked i feel
that it is important to say the trans
thing i really do for a long time i was
like you know what i like i just want to
be like everybody else i want it to be
normalized and that is what i fight for
a lot of the time but i think when
you're so out and loud and proud about
your gender and your journey and all
that i think it's really important to
say yeah i am transgender yeah like put
that in front of everything how do you
feel about that with female comedians
yeah this female comedian because the
intros i got when i came up were
this next comedian is pretty
she's gorgeous you're gonna love her
are you guys ready for a female and i
was like jesus christ when you do that
that's everyone's cue to go well i guess
i should feed my meter and you would
hear the
chairs moving fuck so then
you know
then i had to neuter myself i get it on
stage and go but like i just was like
you know like over compensating for it
yeah i had to because i was just trying
i had to be really rough and sexual to
neuter myself i had to make myself so
sexually unattractive to
men
so i stopped being a woman
and then make all the women in the
audience go oh like she's so tacky my
she's not a wife she's like my i'm good
right so
but the short answer is this uh is that
with you so when
some of my dear dear dear sisters trace
lissette and obsessed with her
did you not meet her at my christmas
party did you not oh no i came super
late member but i have met her before
yeah
but trace is like
like
i i bow down it's just it's it's i have
to work out more and that's it that's it
i just have to work out more and it's
not you're you don't need to get get
minimize your light i just need to
fucking
accept that your body's fucked we're
talking about working out like working
out you know the trace was a marathon
runner yes yeah she's like a sprinter
and she's like a full-on dancer if you
don't think ballroom is not the fucking
hardest i can squat i can do a verse
cowgirl for about 15 seconds
trace is just if you invented reverse
cowgirl
it's so intimidating her body actually
it's so insane and she has a really
pretty face too so it's like come on the
whole thing i mean you y'all know her
from hustlers and um uh you know now is
like
singing some uh rapping and fucking yeah
she does rap yeah i don't want to say i
don't want to fuck her up by going she's
a singer but trans icon as well so so
my thing is when so we were just here
with janice pappas and um
his his daughter's nickname is gigi
gorgeous wait what he has a daughter
named giovannia oh yeah and he calls her
gigi gigi and gigi gorgeous and i go i
was like oh well gg gorgeous is on my
podcast tomorrow i love it and then he
goes who's gg gorgeous you know yeah
it's fine he why would he duh this is
how he learns we just be patient we
don't go why the fuck don't you know we
just imagine that was my reaction i'll
smell that man
we may explain to you now exactly
also please mansplain to me i need the
information don't we all patronize me
fine
i don't care choke me out how am i going
to learn it
we don't we we the the cis white men
they invented antibiotics in airplanes
and we and we just need to get the
information from them right so i'm
actually i'm here to learn never judge
because you have to teach me how to
dethrone you so let's go okay i'm not
going to give you that information not
you but yeah well you're
you're i'm just trying to get on the
right team
so when it when y'all take i'm in we're
gonna take over well i know oh you're
initially in already okay well we'll see
we'll see if i'm a will for a coyote but
um my jealousy might get the best of me
but if i come for the queen i better not
miss i cannot i know i know uh when to
come for the queen and when not to um
so
when uh and look i'm big on everyone's
like folk elon musk and fuck jeff bezos
they made amazon it's ruining the world
true
this is why we're just gonna buy black
owned female odds
ebay whatever
and then and versace if you already
bought it it's fine
oh yeah this is so old we get to listen
to our kelly songs if they're playing
just
if we already bought them they can
michael j they can be played again i'm
not an r kelly fan we just don't buy new
ones right
of all of that but do we do it's case by
case case by case okay
i am i'm not ready to give them all up i
am i'm just getting ready to give up
human nature by michael jackson okay
thriller but i won't buy the new
greatest hits album r kelly is a hard no
hard no hard no hard no but if if he on
someone else but if the
not us be in your own mouth literally so
self suck
but i will say that
you know van gogh
rembrandt they all abused women and were
horrible but it's like i still it is
beautiful when i look at it okay that's
an artist rembrandt you're yeah you're
you're a fucking psycho dega degas
molded t
children ballerinas i mean hello edgar
desjardins so when you see it you'll see
them because um you're getting you
actually have them in your foyer and you
just didn't know right so i'm like i do
do i by the way you married a getty and
just went rembrandt that's an artist i
know so bad you know my records are
terrible i'm literally always like what
does that word mean what does this mean
that's and that's that is why i fell in
love with you
just no shame part of the reason the
first time we met i went what did i say
your your brain should be in a museum
yes i know oh my god when you told me
that i fucking died you were like you
are so fucking quick you are so smart
yeah i died i died because i just like
love you so much and i feel like that's
like such a compliment coming from you
but i'm so lucky that i got to be with
uh uh be in the graces of kathy griffin
and and joan rivers and um totally bob
saget and ollie anderson and they had
different brains they just had different
brains they couldn't they weren't great
at relationships they weren't maybe
great at a lot of things but you have a
joan river's brain do i yes like sick
twisted because i feel like that's like
the best but but the best the sickest
the the best people can act the worst
right so the more sick and twisted you
can go the bigger i know your heart is
you don't call a stupid person stupid
you know what i mean yeah well
well when you say like you're stupid
like
you're not like you're but you know what
i mean
he's stupid but
read the room do you know what i mean
yeah you're no you're not a bully
exactly
you're start you're in high school maybe
so we came from yeah i'm starting to get
some letters from all the tiffany's and
taylor's you went to high school oh my
god so bad i mean it's bully or be
bullied though that's right to be real
my last name was cummings is that oh my
god is that
well i was transgender is my childhood
worse or bad i feel like we're gunning
for
we're going for it i feel like it's
maybe
like a win we tie yeah but so trans icon
just back to this
you're looking good by the way thank you
yeah all i mean the caulk and the grout
and just the it's giving spackle but
like good so when
a a cis-man sees
you and tracing jonna
she's jonah now and laverne cox and
whatever and they don't know that
they're trans icons they're like you go
oh and then they read the
bio and go trans and they go she's trans
you know because you quote pass right
because if we have the money to get all
the surgeries and the privilege you know
whatever and if you put so
it's like
then in that moment you go should i not
should i just have said that was a woman
and now i feel like an asshole because i
was like well she's trans and they're
like she is right but you know what it
really is like life experience it really
is because i feel like for the longest
time like i said i really did want to
just
fade into the world and i would like you
know go out to clubs and not not tell
people that i wanted to hook up with
like i'm trans like it was a huge secret
but at the same time my job was being
inspirational and really sharing my
story and like really just living in my
authenticity but you also didn't sign up
to be a hero but it was the the task was
assigned to you that's another thing
that's another thing and i was i was
like already on the internet and doing
my thing and being so out and proud
before i identified as trans so it was
kind of one of those things where
it i just fell into it like you said
yeah but to go back to trace she
actually was living stealth for a really
really long time and she grew into her
authenticity too so i think it just goes
to show like if you are out and loud and
proud you just like kind of have to make
that decision like i'm gonna be trans in
your face 24 7. but on but but that's
not the only thing that defines you in
life mm-hmm of course not no because
that's the other thing is this person is
like
just happen to be tran that's just one
of the million things about me exactly
you know what i mean because in the end
that is what's going to help normalize
it and people really like i've seen a
billion times people will judge me up
and down for being trans and then they
talk to me for five minutes and they're
like oh she's actually like really
normal and like kind of just like broke
the stigma and like the taboo-ness of
all of it by talking for five seconds
what's the documentary on netflix that
traces in oh i don't i don't know can
you look up trans documentary netflix
because it's really to start with a d
because here's the thing the way
that people were trained disclosure is
that it could be a little bit with
great song too um
so
the way that people were trained to
think of trans women because the way
that they were cast in movies was they
were tricky they were
some like it hot sorry like sex workery
they were scary
required homework and it gives you the
context of here's i mean jerry springer
right no exactly that's how people are
brought up they're scared of it too
because trans women will fuck you
and then right at the buzzer and be like
and i'm a woman and the number one crime
you can commit is to embarrass a man
right you now he's gay and it's like gay
panic and all this stuff which was
practiced in law a lot of the time like
girls would the guys would get away for
literally killing trans women because it
was gay panic but they were passing
trans women they were living their lives
as women it's not like they had they
were met like drag queens like tricking
the men i mean in some cases i'm sure
but that well then you officially are a
woman i mean
the transition's complete um
uh so indefensible uh jenna friedman did
a on her amazon show she was a daily
show correspondent she was on recently
it's uh amazon indefensible amazon
show she did an episode it's about men
that murdered women their wives and then
like the twinkie defense was they got a
defense saying he had had too much sugar
that day
what and and one
so i know of one where it was the
nagging defense like the woman was so
shrill and annoying that he just they
were like and this is literally like
their lawyers like defense attorneys
were like it's called the panic defense
right here yes like she was so fucking
annoying i just had to kill her and
they're like
went yeah you snapped you pushed him to
his legs fucked though or like she was
spending too much that's another one
like or
i don't know i just can't believe that
that was ever a thing it's watch
we just had jenna free been on um so on
geraldo rivera it was not jerry springer
it was on gerald rivera
um there was a guy
who
had like an admirer like he was like a
local tv anchor like he had some kind of
fame i'm getting this wrong and
his admirer came on so he goes in jerry
springer and it's a gay man that hugs
him on tv oh why did i feel like i i
know and then yes and then a couple days
later he killed him
girl and you'd think that like those
kind of shows are fake and set up and
everyone's cast they're not that's so
fucking they're not because and who um
when ricky velez was on remember he said
i used to work at one of those shows you
know trash so hate killing brian donahue
and william dodge is guilty plea uh i
think it was them let me get this right
this might someone just fact check me
and we'll do it
emily's holding the nerf gun so let me
just ask a couple questions so because
um and please set boundaries if i'm
going too far first yeah but my goal so
i did an episode of this show last year
with lady j and jim norton absolutely
ladies it's jana i believe it's john and
now mm-hmm but i've known her for eight
years so it's it's i'm trying to fix my
fucking head
so they're instagrams so also when i
first met janna we we met and it was
like a girl's group of something
and
she said something and hopefully i'm
saying i'm going to be vague enough to
where she would
uh
not a quote not yeah it's not i'm not
betraying her but she said something
about like my grandmother like i went
home and met her for the first time as a
woman right and she or whatever and i
was like and what yeah what was the
reaction total love and pride and
whatever and then i was like what
like you weren't always a woman that was
the vibe
wow so i grew up with basketball players
right all the girls were tall
i was always the shortest girl on the
team i was a point guard i was power
forward and when i went to aau and
played in europe i was a shorter so i
was just like lucky bitch i just was
like i was just like sh you know so then
i was like what so i was the person that
went you're a girl and she was like and
she's so used to it but i was like
oops oops oops but she of course you
know right the ones that are the head of
the line are so patient because they're
so used to that a billion percent it's
like we've been worked down so many
times i feel i get that so much too i
feel like you're also just so like
i don't know present not judgmental like
you really like provide like a safe
space i feel like for people to just
like be like yeah this is my past like
she's not going to fucking judge me the
only thing if someone says you're a girl
if you come for the queen you better not
miss don't interrupt sorry oh is that
why i was like what did she say yeah
it's interesting i interrupt all the
time so bad whitney interrupted it's me
because i know we have a heart out and
i'm so desperate to get everybody this
information i just need to to get it
myself i just need to have patients that
will do a round two yeah so
um get me back brain get me back
adderall don't fail me now i'm not i'm
not on it at all right now people say oh
you're a girl you were saying when
people say to me oh you're a lady j yes
yeah so the only thing you shouldn't be
insulted by is they don't know who gigi
gorgeous is right hello like wait so
wait hold on forgot you fuck forget your
surprise you've never heard of jesus
exactly are you fucking joking okay i
don't care what gender you think i am i
just
i'm famous man now we have a problem you
go do your homework oh you're not okay
so you don't get youtube at your house
cool oh my god so um
so lady jay came on with jim norton who
dates trans women
to his side of the because he was so
ashamed for so long and it was in the
shadows and now openly as with a you
know i i think she'd want to be called a
trans woman um a woman um and anyway so
he came on just
we came on to talk about it because the
hate crimes are
are the hate crimes against trans women
and
men i'm sure too but going up or do we
just have more ability to document it
because i don't think we can say this
has never happened before of course i
think that before there were a lot that
were undocumented right like and i'm not
like the fact you know gatekeeper of all
time but i am so just you okay well i
don't like the numbers but i feel like
it really is like going up because i
feel like it is more prevalent than ever
and people are putting themselves in
dangerous uh situations and it another
thing i want to say too is it's not i
feel like people all the time are scared
to say the wrong thing like in a
conversation or in a public setting like
i don't know if you are right now
because i'm trans i'm like you're not
you know but i'm about to ask you about
trans athletes so oh oh my god nothing's
scary can't wait so i feel like some
people are like i've experienced a lot
where i'm on like talking with them on
their show or whatever and they're like
and i'm like as long as and this is for
everybody listening and watching like as
long as you don't come from a place of
malicious intent or
you know severe ignorance where it's
really disrespectful nothing really can
hurt people's feelings in the long term
because it's just like you're going to
just
fix the situation you're going to
correct that you think you're the one
that's going to hurt me exactly you
can't hurt me i'm numb exactly like i'm
in the space i'm like desensitized to
all of this and i feel like it's just
really important for people to know like
it is okay to ask questions like i know
when the whole non-binary thing really
really blew up and a lot of people were
just fully coming out of the gender
reveal party
oh bitch i can't with that that's
another thing i'm like can we just cut
all gender reveal parties i was so
confused about non-binary people i'm
like i don't have any friends that are
only keep the ones where something
catches on fire because those videos are
funny it's insane whitney stop talking
how dare you we're taking a break emily
you're trying to silence women how dare
you we are now taking a break from gigi
gorgeous to talk about one of our
sponsors
imperfect foods you know a lot about
being imperfect giannis janice is here
for ads yeah i'm here brad um
dude i flew out here for this yeah don't
put your hand in my fucking eyes oh sure
camera eye line keep your hand down old
greek god sorry so imperfect actually is
the new perfect kind of like how
30s the new 20 40s the new 30 fight me
fight me
imperfect foods is a grocery delivery
service offering an entire line of
sustainable groceries that taste
delicious and reduce waste just by
embracing the natural imperfections in
food
plus you can say goodbye to packaging
guilt and perfect food is the only
national grocery delivery company that
makes it easy to return your packaging
after every order do you see how i'm
doing this like a newscaster yeah you're
like the best student in the front of
the class no it's emily yeah
right now in perfect foods it's offering
our listeners 20 off your first four
orders when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and use the promo code whitney again
twenty percent off your first four
orders that's up to eighty dollar value
at imperfectfoods.com offer code when
you use promo code whitney not emily
join me okay well not yet join the
movement at imperfectfoods.com and use
code whitney
so speaking so what y'all just witnessed
was um a mentally ill person needing to
get points with her mom who she's still
are we talking about you or me no we're
talking my mom i'll never get points
without it's you're trying to get the
approval of your mom so i'm trying to
get approval of my dead dad so both of
us need to know better sounds like it's
an uphill climb for both of you
it's the class
i spent a lot of time in therapy talking
about how i
treat you as my mom i have some i have
no maternal instincts why are you
conflating me with your mom it's wild i
don't know ask my better help counselor
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
better help will assess you and your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist honestly
you and i'm on better help so what what
like have you had any like breakthroughs
or time breakthroughs
yeah big time breaks women are human did
you sign that up
well that's not correct so that's a
difficult we're all animals yeah we are
all animals that's true yeah um women
are just below below
society works better that way special
offer for our good free listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
whitney
now you honestly tell me about your
breakthrough now that we're through the
work hard copy yeah mike and back to my
dates uh february 3rd i'll be in
charleston north carolina at the knight
theater sorry to take that again
charlotte not true it's charlotte
and then see here's my brand eventually
right february 4th i will be in
charleston the 5th i'll be in wilmington
delaware which is where um emily
probably lost her virginity at rehoboth
beach february 10th cincinnati ohio
cincinnati's oh oh at the taft theater
february 11th bethlehem pennsylvania
the wind creek events center what native
american tribe did we steal that from
home of jesus february 12th montclair
new jersey this is my shit february 18th
omaha nebraska february 19th we'll be in
kansas city missouri harvest bank
theater
at midland it's by the time we get there
to be called the bitcoin theater let's
be honest and now we are back to gigi
gorgeous
which she is so so here's i'm just going
to say it again a different way for me
which is you can't make a mistake as
long as your heart is in the right place
yes exactly that's totally what i meant
to say it's also not everyone's job to
teach educate you totally so you don't
go okay so what's the difference between
you come to a podcast and then and then
now you can say oh i answered all this
i'm go to go to my podcast my podcast is
blank blank i answer all the questions
there right so oh i've been cornered so
many times and it's just about reading
the room like just be socially fucking
aware if you have a child with you that
wears a skirt who's a boy i'll talk to
them but it's like
it's not your job i'm not your
dictionary i'm not your dictionary it's
not my job to educate you you can find
this all on google yeah you can you find
it all good go to my podcast go to
laverne's go to trace's instagram just
go do now it's your job to go do the
work your homework exactly so in terms
of the
the misgendering the
uh they i'm gonna okay it's gender
nonviolent it's gender non-conforming
now oh i'm not doing it so right here's
my issue
number one
humans are
mortified when they misgender a baby
right okay she's so cute he which
happens all the time
sorry so you telling me that when the
baby can't even see or think you're
worried about its feelings but when it
grows up it is an adult with feelings
and a heart and has worked for it it's
uh
he it's actually she oh my god what the
fuck oh like you suck you're so
difficult
totally they're embarrassing it's
embarrassing yes so when we went from
like secretary to assistant was everyone
like oh
when we went from true when we went from
horse to car when we went you know what
i mean so so humans are
so insecure and don't want to be wrong
and we get embarrassed so we just need
to do a little homework that's all like
you know if some if i say when someone
is like
i don't know the difference between mrs
and missus
which one's married
but we're they're getting rid of that
got it oh are they
well yeah because there's no male
equivalent to miss m-i-s-s
there's only
sir mystery well i'm grandfathered in
and i'm keeping it till i know the new
word and then yeah i like mrs getty
you're an ms you're miz which is single
we're single yes that's right that's
great news that's bad news no well
you're too old to be we're too old to be
a miss m.i.s.s
oh no by the way swing in a miss
i don't like it oh my god i don't like
swinging a miz
wow
you wait until it is
kicking i will be a miss but the point
is um so you just get married what's
married again miss
how i think about it is uh mr is mr and
then mrs is mrs okay which is like more
formal sense right because they all the
man owns them they have done now so so
you just got married and i'm kind of
just don't know you that well and i'm
like um hello mrs gorgeous
mrs getty gorgeous oh shit sorry yeah
this is getting gorgeous but i thought
wait miss is married i called you missus
missus yeah mrs getty gorgeous married
but you have to correct me
mrs getty gorgeous is mrs married mrs
married mrs what's misses
then what's this what am i single if i
miss this company miss miss i'm sorry
mess excuse me thank you
miss these conversations aren't that
hard you can do it you can do it at
school be egoless um
miss getty gorgeous oh actually it's mrs
i'm so sorry imagine do you see this
fucking ring yeah i see it i see the
cubic zirconia a mile away cubic
zirconium
oh my god it's mortimite i see i see
that blood diamond miles away
um
i want to put it on right now um so i
want a black diamond from kerry sexton
city too oh yeah oh my god you and the
memorabilia it's insane so
we're designed to be mortified right
so such a weird concept
because it's why now i think also it
comes from a place of embarrassment
that's also like people get angry about
it you know like people are like well
what the fuck like what the fuck but i
think sometimes people do it and they
feel really really bad like it's like
shame they don't want to call you
they don't want to misgender you they
know that that's going to hurt your
feelings and especially in like a queer
space like if you go to like a queer bar
or something like that or you're just
walking around and like we ho it's like
sometimes you're like oh that person
like i want to say she but like i'm not
sure so it almost leads to lack of
communication altogether you know i am
not going to go around that group i'm
not going to talk to that person because
i don't want to hurt their feelings
which then separates two people that
could be best friends or learn something
from the whole situation altogether if
although it's not your job to educate at
a bar it's fun time those people can go
like ask next time also
if a woman is five months pregnant i'm
just not talking to her at all i because
i don't want to ask and if i get it
wrong it's it's killing myself oh my god
how long are you to do yes i'm suicide
instantly so it's the same thing yeah i
mean it is so so sometimes people go you
know i'm gonna wait till it's a little
more obvious right or maybe she'll bring
it up so be like hey do you want a shot
i can't i'm pregnant you want them to
say something right or you know so so
it's also like
you know i think that yeah the movies
people watched it you know where it's
jerry springer and it was men in a wig i
mean men and wigs were
performed shakespeare i mean it was men
and with people accused mae west of
being a man because it was like you know
fucking love her by the way she's my
everything she's why we are here in
lucille ball they created it themselves
mae west started started her career at
40. really get vodka i want to learn
more about her i just love her yeah so
she rodney dangerfield these are the
people we look to right so um was a sex
symbol in her fucking 50s unheard of on
her and she made so much money and like
she like elvira also not to be
not to slip through the cracks of
history mm-hmm uh elvira started became
a sex symbol at like what 4550 as the
elvira so crazy and went into the
fucking men's and it was like a death
sentence if you were 30 back then and so
like even younger and said not only am i
going to be in your movies they're my
movies i own them and they're called
elvira they're not called sexy vampire
girls right
and gay and like
yes um so you know there's a i think
what happens is when in societies things
start changing people don't like change
right they right men like you know and
women i know a lot of women they're like
i'm not doing the gender thing it's not
it's not a gender thing who is resistant
to the gender thing it's we're all
terrified of being embarrassed because
if i say
you know so i had a friend that had a um
a child that someday would wear skirts
some days would wear uh
play with trucks it was just back and
forth and they were calling it gender
creative oh that's cute but then i'm
talking to a trans uh friend of mine uh
and i said oh
this they're doing trans kid play dates
not trans sorry but gender creative play
dates right that have all kinds of so
that they can i think that's cute but
all kids are born like wanting to
experiment with all right right so then
they went it's gender non-conforming
and then
because but i was just saying the word i
learned yesterday and now there's a new
one or it's a different one see that's
always going to change though like an
example that i can think is um
when you got sexual reassignment surgery
i you i said that we said sex change in
my day sex change exactly and like i'm
like i don't think that that's
necessarily offensive but i was
corrected as well like last time i used
it someone's like gender confirming
surgery and i was like okay that makes
sense to me but i think honestly the way
that like if anybody's listening and
they're just like freaked out by the
whole thing or is you know going so
balls to the wall to say i'm not fucking
doing this gender thing i'm not doing
this trans thing people can you know i'm
not going to be around that they can do
their own i'll hire them as sex workers
in the shadows but i will not learn the
names exactly and it'll be my most
beautiful princess she her herself
behind doors they'll get better hand
jobs than the cis women i mean of course
naturally but i feel like the best way
to approach this is
really just you have to put yourself in
in the casual setting make it casual if
you're like oh yeah she's over there
someone's going to be like oh no that's
actually a he it's like oh okay cool no
in my day they said he she he right it
i mean we've come so far so so but in
that moment i got corrected
and i was and my ego went you're a piece
of shit i knew it so so
if the matter you get at yourself the
more you have to look at yourself
because if you know your intentions were
in the right place
you know
i went oh my god i fucked it up i fucked
it up i heard that like i fucked it up
i'm a piece of shit
that now has to do with my childhood you
know what i mean that's me
going you're wrong you're not good
enough or not getting the attention i
need as a child i'm going if you weren't
such a piece of shit maybe your parents
would pay attention to you more or
whatever when they were just drinking or
whatever they were doing they were
living their lives or my mom was working
five jobs and i decided to take it
personally that i wasn't good at you
know so then then
if you're upset by this take it as an
opportunity to look at why you had that
reaction and why oh i'm bad it's a
really smart way to think about it i
feel like i'm ignorant i'm i'm i'm a
piece of shit i knew it and it was like
how would you have known exactly and
like sometimes the person will take it
personally it's just kind of a little
tricky situation but ask and that's
another thing you can just ask someone
your pronouns like literally on like
facebook and instagram and like email
and everything now it's like she hers he
his like you could ask someone hey what
are your pronouns by the way and then
just like move the fuck on because we
can't talk about gender all day like no
we don't have time we have shit to do
right it's like just
get it and then just listen to my
podcast when you have a chance and like
we're done yes you know not my i mean
yours yes um and then so i just mean you
have a podcast george.com just skim it
you know yeah the answer is for anybody
out there when you want to learn how to
play golf you're not you don't go out
then you're like why can't i play golf
you'd have to go learn it's just like
anything yes but um it's like all the
people with the good intentions like
you know look
white guys made
airplanes and antibiotics and like you
know what i'm saying we're not thankful
for those just be thankful it's the
thing about bezos that i got off track
on bezos and and elon musk is like you
know hot takes hot takes people just
unsubscribing um
emily's gagging emily's like i'm going
back to snl um
uh
so
is that but listen to me jeff bezos
he made it so women didn't spend four
hours a day in the grocery store and at
rite aid and running errands and home
depot
so
amazon made it so women had three
assistants and it freed up time for them
remember when we had to go to women
mom's had to go to rite aid three times
a week you know
and
tesla although not everyone should get
attacked it's too expensive now but auto
drive is going to make it so women when
they're picking they can run their
business while they're picking up their
kids like i
i always want to fight for going this
current bad thing is ultimately good if
we just think hard enough right like two
sides of the coin vibe so we shouldn't
only buy from amazon that's i'm really
working on that if i can get it on etsy
black owned store just do the work to
research like you know right it starts
with you stop buying the yeah so
anyway um so a big a big humdinger
we're in a little bit of a pickle
about
the trans women in sports and so
this is the thing no one wants to
fucking touch right and the one person
that's touching it is coming from his
perspective of sports and rogan
this interview
was recorded with gigi gorgeous on
monday the 24th monday the 24th of
january it is now february the 1st
which means the
referencing joe rogan
there has been some controversy that i'm
not going to weigh on right now because
i'm not studied up enough on it
after jordan peterson went on rogan so
just don't don't allow you
having feelings or thoughts in comments
about jordan peterson's uh what he said
on joe rogan's appearance recently if
you even
know that happened you may not give a
shit but we did not address it uh
because it was shot pre
this and we're not time travelers we're
not time travelers
i mean well
you haven't
done i have some edibles downstairs that
that might
change your mind um
so this was solely about
please just view the rest of this in a
vacuum without the current controversy
going on with those comments
if possible
thank you i don't want you guys to think
that gg gorgeous and i just like we're
tiptoeing around talking about that
current issue when she comes back for
round two we will do that and yes i am
wearing a uh yellow vest
that i got at a flea market and i can
smell it
that's your upper lip
you know his his point which i i
the point is what was his point i never
heard a quote from him so his point
because he does mma he's the voice of
mma finance right and so it's i loved
fear factor growing up too yes and this
is where he is
it's we're at the time in history right
where there's mma for men and mma for
women of course i made a movie called
the female brain i'm just saying we
cannot say right now that cis women are
all cis women are not as
strong as cis men period we've all
agreed with that
and when they fight it's a crime
you know what i'm saying right
so but we're better at other things it's
like if if you a in a mental fight i'll
win every time a physical fight you
might win that's how we vote i'm strong
i know well so the point is right now
if a trans woman is going to do mma
how long how far along in her transition
should she be
so can if she transitioned if she's 25
transitions 35 i'm sorry 26
can she be in a cage with a cis woman
see here's the thing i feel like this is
so tricky because of the levels in your
body
like i do labs frequently and measure my
testosterone and my estrogen as many
trans people do if not all should be
doing at least
and i feel like that has something to
play with i just saw caitlyn jenner was
on the news and she was basically just
saying that you know they sh they
shouldn't be allowed it's not it's not
they have like bigger respiratory system
and you know they can swim faster and
jump higher and punch harder but you're
forgetting about fucking will and grit
right and i think
coming from a former athlete i was
literally on my way to the olympics i
was a professional diver and i was like
national champion in canada like i i
very oh nova's gagged
by the way were you a diver no i'm just
so impressed oh thanks nova
yeah so by the way there's also the tiny
not saying they should be in a cage it's
not mine to decide but right when you're
fighting for your life you get stronger
i mean yes i'm sure i mean i'm not very
familiar with that sport but i will say
in in diving and in swimming i mean
they're kind of they go two and two like
whenever dude all the divers
shave anyway
right
more yeah yeah to like get that clean
entry um and it just like looks better
your body's like so hot when you're
diving and swimming you're just like so
like so ripped and it's it's an
aesthetic it's an aesthetic sport i mean
you're right naked
by points all about form and all of that
but i feel like you know if i go back to
like when i was diving and i was trans i
would be devastated if i had to compete
with the boys
you know that would be killing me and i
think you know there's already enough
hatred there's already enough violence
and i think
that telling little kids who are trans
that they can't play the sport they love
is doing more harm and we're going to be
losing more lives because that is
someone's dream you're crushing
someone's dream so i feel like there's
got to be a way where we can just really
level out the the hormones in people's
bodies where we're really gauging that
and you have to be at this number or
whatever the fuck they decide to play
but trans people have to play and
they're gender sports people going into
medicine we need trans doctors oh abs
we need way more for sure i'm talking
about the ones that are now 25 to 35 not
the ones coming up so the ones now right
so great there's got to be some kind of
system like they can't just say no yeah
we can't just say no is there a third
option just for now while right like
make it work like we see what's going on
right now i mean literally starting the
transports league that only lasts for
five or six years until we
you know because you know uh it's gotta
happen something's gotta give joe was
talking about because there are some
people that will take advantage and then
make trans people look bad totally so so
i don't know the metrics on this i just
admitted i didn't know something oh my
god were we rolling
i heard it coming and i cut
thank you pat thank you
bad nose taking another break from gigi
gorgeous
giannis is still here thank god
now we're going to talk about our
sponsor doordash
yes
last night what did we do dash to the
house greek food
spanish
we had dormadas
doordash like it makes it easier for you
to have those family meals without who's
gonna clean it up and i was like
and we watched it and they just dropped
it at the front yep contactless delivery
you get what you want to eat right now
and right to your door with doordash
along with the restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash
get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour for a limited
time our listeners can get 25 off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter code
gfy that's 25 off up to ten dollar value
right in my teleprompter and zero
delivery you're not you don't just
memorize orders
so we have a podcast where i get
teleprompters for people so they don't
have to re okay
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code gfy if you
get it you can read online don't forget
that's code gfy for 25 off your first
order with door dash subject to change
terms
apply and conditions nope just terms so
i know when you think whitney cummings
you think
low energy
like how does she like she's we need to
get caffeine in this bee
hydration yeah is the new adderall yeah
i'm telling you it's the new look at me
everyone's why don't you have so much
energy i am nice she's hydrated give me
a a blood test yeah because also you
know why else i would are you the bitch
that wakes up in the morning and the
pillow crease is on your face all day
that means you're dehydrated when you
take a scrunchie off do you have a dent
in your arm
you're dehydrated check the wedding ring
the same way that you know okay stay
hydrated
but i'm single ladies let's fuck
can we get back to how hydrated i am
also people are like did you get a
facelift like what it like you said yes
but i also do iv so
i got it it wasn't my face it got lifted
whoever's face is but i have not gotten
a facelift no you have not the
difference between my under eye bags
when i'm using water and i put the
liquid iv i'm sorry i think water's
disgusting it tastes like someone else's
spit mixed with calm i can't do just
regular water so this is what gets me to
drink it yep and i my favorite flavor is
the pina colada because i feel like i'm
on vacation right when i wake up in the
morning when i taste pina colada it um
makes it reminds me when i was breastfed
um and it comes in these little uh
packets has b3 b5 b6 b12 and all of
emily's bra sizes and vitamin c and it's
non-gmo and dairy free free from gluten
dairy and soy
um so everyone with their fake allergies
can still have it grabs look what i'd be
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidity.com
and use code whitney and check out we
were allergic to all those things too we
just moved through it that's 25 off
anything you order when you use promo
code whitney at liquidive.com experience
better hydration today at liquidity.com
promo code whitney it's been a pleasure
hosting this podcast and i can't wait to
see what i do next now back to gigi
gorgeous i wonder if she's hiring
[Laughter]
so bridget fedocy uh who has the podcast
dumpster fire is brilliant got naturally
pregnant 43. um really oh wow mm-hmm
come on robot 30's a new 40 exactly
she's a robot um uh
and
she's like like
i think that
this is gonna sound get taken out of
context and sound really bad um but the
idea of like i believe sometimes the
more you're willing to say something
really uncomfortable is being more
pro-trans because it's going there are
some people that will take advantage oh
absolutely that's just being a realist
so there are some people that now in
prisons men get arrested and they go
well i identify as a woman
and they're going into women's prisons
oh so
and then they go well what are we gonna
do right so there's gotta just be like a
how long have you been on hormones have
you ever bought heels can i just look at
your credit card receipts have you did
you did magic did you watch you know did
you watch gilmore girls like dude like i
we need some kind to protect
the stereotype from continuing they're
sneaky they're tricky you can't trust
them and then see we let a trans man
into a prison and he raped someone so
everybody
so when i played sports it was this we
played it was basketball and it was we
stay
uh every night
uh ten o'clock whitney you have to shoot
10 free throws in a row and if you miss
the whole team runs 30 suicides why just
you and you don't run any well it was
different every night oh got it but put
you under the max pressure oh i would
hate that slash love it by the way the
fact that we called them suicides yeah
whoa i'm sorry the life is worth it is
that what we call enough it gets better
i mean i feel like at the core everybody
wants an athlete like we know especially
you and i know being at the former
athletes that is it's your whole life
like you really do have to fucking train
like this is not a joke so i think if
someone's coming forward like i'm a
trans woman i want to compete with the
other girls it's like okay let's look
into that we're not just going to be
like everyone in you know especially we
don't want all the girls in either
exactly so there's gotta be some kind of
vet system yeah and it's gotta be fair
yeah and maybe they start a little a
little bit more savagely but i know
there's a swimmer and her name is
escaping me but she's a trans woman she
actually competed her name is escape
escape escape the system
yes so she competed um professionally
and like she's super major like michael
phelps has commented on her and like
she's like in the swimming world she
competed as her previous gender when she
was male and then when she went on the
hormones and all that she was like okay
i'm going to compete with the women yeah
and did and won and everyone has this
huge stink about her they're like oh
well she competed so long as a male and
then the other but then if i could get
the name of the ellip trans
olympic women that lost in the shot put
because their whole thing was if you're
trans you're going to win you're going
to win right now it's like it's really
not like that but always the biggest and
strongest and they don't always win
laurel hubbard
and me yeah trans uh what olympian
played as a woman
came in like third place right like cis
women beat her you know what i mean
because she's like this is her first
olympics why would she but i mean it's
only fucking natural they're not always
going to win like that's just so crazy
that's what we need more of we need to
see more examples of that here's what
i'll say the thing that no one will say
and that's my fucking lot in life give
it to us is that it it's basically being
talked about
with two trans athletes in connecticut
and they
keep winning the relay races
by like i mean so much beyond right but
nobody will talk about the fact that
they're black
oh so if you had black cis women on your
team
they might be beating the who knows you
i'm saying so they're also the only two
black girls on the team mm-hmm
from what i know okay so it's like you
know so much more than me this is no
it's just it's just a different kind of
like i'm just i i do my research to then
go to you and go what do we do right
because we because so black people can't
solve racism it's a white problem if
they would have solved it be solved so
now we have to go here's the problem we
have
how do we solve it do we need a six or
seven year intermediary
i agree with that actually i really do i
agree with you maybe we can have two
first places it's two second places you
know what i mean like well that will
never fly i just we come to be the best
when we're at the adjusted hormones you
know what i mean so if there has to be
some kind of system i agree with doing
like a test run for a few years or
having like a different i don't know a
different category so no one thinks
anything's being unfairly taken from
them right so we can't let like the
propaganda machine this might not be a
now thing
she's in it the eyelash curlers might
not be a now thing and if i lose an eye
i'll just get stronger so you know that
every time i get hurt we don't need
whitney cyclops so
i'm scared of that power p s y
psych-ward clubs
come on it gets better
so like what's the solution and no one
wants everyone wants to just say take a
side and you can't just say no i feel
like that's like fucked up too you know
i feel like and people coming out and
saying no it's wrong like you know
they're always going to win and all that
bullshit i feel like it is just so
unfair to say that because like you said
you just gave an example where someone
somebody didn't win yeah and especially
for trans people to come out and say
that like everyone is totally like valid
to their own opinion i'm not saying that
you're wrong i'm just saying living
growing up trans i was in professional
sports before i came out as trans but i
can't imagine back in the day being told
i can't do something that i love but
that was my dream but you were chosen to
be the one that dismantles the system
and you had to get it the heart your
carry struck so it's like you had to do
it the hard way with a smile on your
face so then you open the door for the
people behind you right so it's like but
you know
we are it's like
we're we're talking about unfair
advantages that's what we're talking
about right so
basically it's like if i'm a mom and my
uh
because we always go not my
angel
oh he's pro-tram because you were being
strong and he was like she's the alpha
so you're the new alpha based on that
um
so
the complicated thing is so i come from
you know commander basketball and it was
i would watch parents fight the
physically fight the coaches when
they're physically
would oh oh bitch my eyes off and
parents off moms i might be that mama so
if if a kid didn't get time on the bench
your time on the floor was just on the
back that's embarrassing i know that's
humiliating but that's the biological
urge we have as mama bears so
these connecticut moms and dads i don't
know
them
carol and christine come on hartford i
mean come on so they
you know
their daughter they've been training
their daughter to
get a scholarship
to college we just need to cancel
college first of all but that's we'll
get there we don't need it it's
ridiculous oh i don't know her and then
someone that recently transitioned but
was always in that body and but they
just recently transitioned two years ago
yeah well there's no opportunity to do
it any earlier right because rupaul
wasn't on tv and gigi gorgeous wasn't
around they didn't know it was an option
i mean that's that's the t it's like
when when like is it too late for me
should i just not play the sport
yeah or
and then but then
also right because the thing is two
things can be true at once
that girl did work her ass off and
someone came in at the buzzer that
worked their ass off too
who just had you know what i mean it was
a confluence of things there's got to be
a fucking solution there has to be
okay
it's 2 30. yeah we could do like a
little bit and then just the last
question and we will also pick this up
on a zoom or somehow if there's because
we're gonna get questions because my
thing is
is
i just have for my appalachia i have the
bravery to ask these questions and i
want to be wrong like i wanna be asked
the stupid questions
for other people so they need this
though i feel like people are literally
going to listen to this and be like this
is how we should handle the sports issue
like i i would love to hear some like
really really logical reasonable fair
opinions it's not your job to solve it
right and it's like maybe i'll like hear
something and be like oh my god that's
perfect and maybe we go for a couple
years there's two leagues and we adjust
for level of testosterone right exactly
if that's the thing that makes people
that's the vibe muscle mass i don't know
what it is and then we can have the ugly
conversation about
and leslie jones said it about the
quote super slaves just look her up
about how black people were bred to be
basically
right i mean of course and then the news
announcer who's the news announcer that
got fired for talking about the quick
twitch
he said
he was at a press conference and
everyone's like so why like the coach
was like why are you guys losing why
can't you win and he's just like you
know it's just the defense is a little
rough and i think uh we need more black
people on the team
and then a sports reporter covered it
and defended him and was like there's a
quick tw there's different muscle fibers
i don't know if any of this is true at
all it might all be propaganda and and
um ways to change it's a theory it's a i
don't know if it's true or not yeah
jimmy snyder genies jimmy the greeks
jimmy the greek snyder so so yeah so do
your research i'm probably wrong but
bill bird has a great bit on it i will
say though just on a close i really want
to say this i feel like it is so
important to think about the levels of
testosterone and estrogen because when
you are first firstly starting your
transition they start you off on
hormones if that's what you why can't
you sit at home every day
why can't you i mean can you test your
i'm sure there's like a lab that you
could take so so so but they they go off
of the number of it and then they
monitor there's the lgbt center in tons
of states fantastic it's not expensive
so do we put liz holmes to work in jail
to make the the hormone testing machine
i mean at home hormone testing i mean
literally i feel like it's going to get
there like that they monitor what what
uh medicine you're on right need a
thermometer for hormones right and then
just like literally do like a quick
little test but yeah they monitor your
medicine and all the thermometer nova
kaplan
w-h-o-r-e nova
we've built like four businesses um
so because then the last thing i'm gonna
say and then well emily has a question
well no i just wanted you you were
saying you wanted to close on something
oh yeah that i really feel like it is it
is that that's always what i thought i'm
like well if they're worried that
they're going to be so much better like
there's got to be a way to test it and
it's it's it's the estrogen for me
that's just where my brain goes i don't
know if there's a better way but
literally when you start medically
transitioning with hormone replacement
therapy they literally tell you oh your
levels are here so you're going to take
more estrogen like it's a medical thing
and by the way women our hormones also
change every day exactly that's why
there's peaks in it there's a shock for
the estrogen it peaks and it goes down
it's a real thing
is there a level that's been agreed upon
point to be above or below like that
would be the the argument is what's the
number but here's the thing by the way
because cis women normally i think are
at like a level 400 estrogen i'm not a
doctor but i think it's somewhere around
that and by the way doctors aren't
doctors they're working on data from 60
years ago uh-huh there's no data on this
no one's stuck people would be like they
need to be 100 only and whatever that
that that number is we agree on
and then next year it might change
because we were wrong and next year so
so this whole thing where we live by all
the rules that
that men from 300 years ago fucking made
we just have to go reassess reassess do
we need an electoral college do we need
is this a supreme court system it worked
it's worked really well up in here this
system worked it now
it was just revealed to be broken
um and obsessed and then the one thing
that we'll just get to next time so no
one thinks i danced around it
which is
um i hired a female comedian to play a
trans woman on my sitcom 10 years ago
i didn't know any i didn't even know it
was an option to ask i was trying to br
i was trying to talk about what that
looked like i did it imperfectly
harder you can do it you're an athlete
frank i don't give a fuck that's versace
that's versace
and you're in like so there is the
conversation about like can elliot paige
play a girl in five like can we oh i'm i
love that we want everyone to play
everything but we just wanted to the
best person to win right but during so
it's like my thing with this is like
like we just said it is
trans women should be able to play trans
women it's gonna be may the best man or
woman win may the best they win or
whatever um let me not get that wrong
but for now
they're they're we're at such a
disadvantage that actually we need to
give a head start of no you need to look
at every trans woman's audition tape and
we need to get
every job in hollywood has been gotten
by it was nepotism before it was you
know like it's never been fair so let's
just
overcompensate oh everything over
corrects yes exactly we're in an over
correction
and then we'll we'll creep back right
and by the way i'd be remiss can i close
on a robin tran joke sure
because a lot come on tran i love robin
tran tear ann
yeah can you pull up robin tran uh
please um
robin goes i'm such a lazy trans person
can you pull up robin tran on the main
tv um uh
robin tran uh opens on i'm such a lazy
trans person my email is still robert
tran gmail.com dad
dad and then
and then
addresses
like
addresses you realize like everyone's
mad at white trans women like they even
come after other trans women you're not
doing right and then
and then she goes uh
uh the reason is can we play a video can
we play stand up
yeah the reason right white trans women
are so mad is that they became a double
minority overnight like they used to
have the male privilege it's very true
and then they lost it was like wait it's
like you transitioned to be a woman we
get treated like shit you didn't know
about that yeah exactly yeah this is
this is just being a woman uh-huh and
then uh robin says on top of it yeah and
then robin says i actually upgraded in
life because i was a vietnamese man
and now i'm a asian woman and like all
the white men want to marry us you know
so it does hilarious we'll put this in
post pat just leave it because we'll
kick her out of here oh here we go can
we just play i am a vietnamese
transgender lesbian
[Applause]
means i am a triple minority so
if any of you call me a bad name you go
to jail for 50 years so it's great you
know
i think that i'm the best vietnamese
transgender lesbian comedian in the
country you know i think uh
i think that's me
[Applause]
victory by default's still a victory so
i don't know what you want from me
and robin uh if i'll pitch it off camera
but would be great on your podcast one
day oh absolutely like how she in l.a
yes work yes perfect and yeah so i'll
hit her up and uh
the best and is like i i like said to me
once in a conversation like i want to
transition more but i don't want to
spend all this money on makeup and then
be behind still like i'm just going to
wait till i have um and then also we
talked about the transport stuff and she
was like i was like
you know
she can say this i can't but i was just
brainstorming with her the idea of like
like the trans women
at the marathon line with all the cis
women just being like are those
pigtail french braids the reason they
run so fast because they're trying to
get away from your fucking french braid
like it's just like they're running so
fast because they don't mean a photo
with you right exactly
hideous swimming exactly just like why
are like all these just funny things of
like like the reason you trans women are
so fast is they're used to running from
people trying to kill them on the street
like if you don't want us to run fast
stop killing us
that's everything there's such a way to
do that and i feel like it you really
really does help that she is trans i
really do believe like we want to be
equal we want to be a part of the
conversation like make fun of us like
make it normal
so tv is stupid we're not curing cancer
we're not building spaceships got it got
it got it but will and grace you can now
connect uh and uh michelle obama told me
this i've told this story before oh this
conference call it wasn't to me directly
um uh she's too nervous to meet me in
person for breakfast yeah um yeah so she
said uh in their last year in office did
a conference call with show runners and
said we can now link people are by the
way checking their phone to make sure
they didn't put it on two at 2x fast
like listening fast
um
she said we can now link the passage of
marriage equality to will and grace
she said that because there were so many
people that had just never met a gay
person
and now gay per people were in their
living room right and they're like i
love like these are my buddies and then
they go to the bathroom like of course
i'd want them to be able to get married
right they're my buddy they were in your
living room exactly so that's why the
visibility conversation matters that's
why we need you know yes people like
diversity diversity it's like it's not
for
the adults it's for we need trans a
trans doctor in grey's anatomy so the
kids watching can go like oh i could do
that
exactly that's that's all it is exactly
the fact that there's like a trans
person on euphoria right now that's
really not it's it's it's made a little
bit of a moment especially in season one
but then it just goes away and she's
just trans it's fucking the story isn't
about being trans about being sneaky
doesn't get killed off i mean benton
explains this perfectly of like every
gay character has to either be like evil
or wrong murdered
like sick whatever but you know it's
just
we will stop
i can control myself
okay that was good i'm gonna transition
into a patient so i'm transitioning into
me a patient person who can shut their
fucking pig cum pig mouth and respect
your time
give me a don't ride elephants do not
ride elephants
um what's that about
you should you'll love my podcast okay
no that's how we close every podcast
okay just it's it's i like to say at the
end bob barker used to always say at the
end of what did he host price is right
um uh spay and neuter your animals oh so
when you have a platform i i like
i'm not doing everything because i can't
but it's don't touch uh lions tigers or
bear baby lions tigers or bears we never
touch baby apex predators we don't go to
zoos we don't like so we just say it's
don't ride elephants don't ride
elephants not even like for fun
like never
i want to ride an elephant
me too i mean this is the wrong room to
be safe and i did it but that's why
that's why we say it i want to too but
it's bad we can make robot elephants so
so yeah we just try to like find some
like blah blah blah blah black own
business it's time i'm done like bye bye
black owned but it's just whatever we
can say
you know i and i and my videos and my
show would stay gorgeous stay gorgeous
so that when people that's my little tip
so that when when
someone's out in in they're disrespected
stay gorgeous don't worry stoop fly high
stay stable yes in the mind and the exit
i'm staying i'm not even i'm not gonna
bite your makeup looks great
i kept you i woke up like this
what makeup no it's good it's insane
okay yeah it's good
um thank you um podcast real quick and
just any uh the other couple places we
can find you well i actually just
started uh one of my own podcasts it's
called queerified because it's a safe
space once you listen you've been clear
it was pr it was pretty safe whitney's
been on it was really fun we like to
have fun with that you should call in we
have a hotline she taught me about eye
drops that white in your eyes oh lumify
yeah i have you have you need i do know
yeah vise yeah because i came to your
house stone and you're like um
that's what it was
well thank you i love that i love you
we'll get you out of here
oh my god a dream
[Music]
ah
oh
[Applause]